- Going on an adventure today.
We're gonna find some people, meet them,
and live their life with them.
Can I come with you?
That's what I'm gonna ask people.
(upbeat music)
Hi there.
Where are you headed?
Smoking section?
Can I come with you.
- No.
- No?
(buzzer)
- I'm headed to a meeting in two minutes.
- Uh, can I come with you?
- Yeah.
- Really?
- No.
What are you all waiting for?
- James Bay.
- I can't go to that.
Alright.
How you doing?
Hey, I'm Keith.
Nice to meet you, Johnny,
where are you headed?
- I'm headed home.
- Can I come with you?
- Uh, it wouldn't be the best time,
my roommate is very hungover.
- You want to call him?
- He is on crutches right now.
- Then he needs support of friends.
- They want to support you.
I don't know.
- It's just me, my buddy
Zach, Luis, and Kyle.
So like, two camera man
and one sound guy and me.
Sweet.
Alright, Miguel, alright, peace out buddy.
We're going over.
And you said your name was Jason?
- Johnny.
- Johnny!
- Thanks for remembering.
- (beep) that up, (beep)
that up real quick.
So, Johnny, where are you from?
- I'm from New York.
- So why'd you move out here?
- I'm an actor.
- Oh, nice.
What's your coolest thing?
- I'm in Hand of God on Amazon.
- Oh, that's sick!
- Yeah, with Ron Perlman.
- Does that pay you good?
This is where the taco
party's gonna be later.
What up taco party!
Woo!
Johnny, you were gonna go
get groceries at Trader Joes
before we came.
- Yep.
- But then we interrupted you.
So we're actually gonna go
make sure you run your errands
first, 'cause I don't want
to (beep) up your whole day.
(upbeat music)
I just got kicked out of the
store so I hope Keith and
new friend are having a good time.
- So you're gonna carry my groceries?
- Yeah.
So we're gonna go meet Miguel now.
- Yep.
- At your house.
- And Kramer.
- And Kramer, the dog!
Hair cuts are 12 bucks right there?
For a wash and cut?
That's not bad.
- Not for me, they'll
charge me like a girl.
We can actually go in through this--
- Oh, through the creepy alley, Johnny.
- Through the Batman alley.
- Whose sofa?
This is nice!
- Oh, yeah, I forgot about this.
- Any you pay $1800 for this?
- Yeah!
- Nice, that's a steal, buddy.
To Tuesday.
- Alright.
- What a fun Tuesday we're having.
What's next?
(grunting)
I can see why would you
cast in some Amazon shows.
(Johnny laughs)
So you just live with this
construction noise all the
time, huh?
- Yeah, it's kind of not ideal.
- I hear Miguel up there.
- Yeah, you can hear his
bionic body walking around.
- Hey, how are you?
Could I come up to you?
Are you decent?
- He's brushing his teeth.
- Should I shoot this big
thing with the bio-hazard
symbol on it?
- Yeah.
(laughs)
It did what I thought it would.
How do I?
So?
(both laughing)
Miguel (beep) coming in hot.
Making fun of everybody's plaid.
We're gonna clear things up,
we're gonna get in a cool,
sexy TV show format to interview Miguel.
Hey, what's up, we're here
live from Johnny and Miguel's
apartment, the person we've all
been waiting to meet Miguel.
How are ya?
- I'm doing well there, sir.
- The real elephant in the
room, Miguel, you got crutches,
you got a bum foot there.
- Oh right, yeah.
I'll show you.
I'm a bartender and I was
polishing some glasses,
snapped the glass, stabbed
myself in the hand.
20 minutes later I go to go
under the bar and the wine stem
is still on the ground standing
straight up and I step on it
and it goes through my
shoe, stabs me in the foot.
And I'm like, "Oh my God,
it's in there, it's in there."
I pull this thing out, blood
is just pouring out onto
the floor of the bar.
- Through your shoe?
- Through my shoe.
I get to the table, I take my shoe off,
and then blood just starts pouring out.
- God, that's gross.
Oh my God.
- Yeah, it's still black and blue on top.
- Yeah.
Oh yeah, you got something
jabbed up in your foot once.
(laughing)
What do you do out here?
- As of late I've been doing
some screenplay writing.
- Tell 'em what the movie is about.
- Alright, sure.
So it's three girls on spring
break in Spain and they're
leaving Madrid, they're
going to Barcelona,
but along the way they find
this charming charismatic
Spaniard man.
- This never works out well.
- He traps them and basically
uses their bodies as
fertilizer for his vineyard.
- (beep)
- Yeah.
- We'd love to cut to a clip of the movie.
So here it is.
I hope you guys enjoy it.
Wait, I'm sorry, but do you
have any chocolate of any kind?
- Of course we do, we have
an assortment of bon bons.
- Well I'll take three orders
and thank you for being
so pleasant.
- Did you just order
three orders of bon bons?
- And don't forget the
cheese and charcuterie plate.
I haven't been this high and
hungry in over two decades.
(both laughing uncontrollably)
I will murder you and
put you in my garden.
- Do you promise?
- Wow, I think we can all say
that was a pretty impressive
piece of work, guys.
- That whole laugh was
exactly how I pictured it.
- I don't know if we are
actually deserving of any Oscars
for what we did today, but
I think we're all deserving
of some tacos.
So I'd love for you guys to meet me.
Zach and I are gonna go on
and head to Calle Tacos,
the taco place we would
love to sponsor us.
So that we can have tacos every Tuesday,
making every Tuesday Taco Tuesday.
Ah yeah, it's your old
buddy Keith and I got tacos.
Who wants tacos for Tuesday?
(cheering)
Yeah, I got tacos in a bag!
I got tacos in a bag!
Tacos in a bag, alright!
It's been an amazing day, I
made a new friend, Johnny,
new friend Miguel, and fed
a lot of ladies some tacos
for Taco Tuesday.
Thank you for letting me come with you!
(cheering)
Taco Tuesday, Taco Tuesday!
Now, who's James Bay?
Really, I don't know anything.